hi my name is David Clarke I'm the
bureau chief for Reuters in East Africa
for me bureau chief in West Africa and
on basis I was moderating a panel about
the transformation of western central
Africa we had the president of nigeria
Goodluck Jonathan attending we had a
leaker dangote I put his richest man we
also had genre beyond from the aggregate
company civic affairs in abidjan it was
a wide-ranging discussion obviously but
the themes that came out really were
that in West Africa there are still
quite a few obstacles to regional
integration beard language via the
relative size of the Nigerian economy
compared to these other economies and
and the fact that economic integration
is not is picking up but hasn't really
hasn't really overcome a lot of the
obstacles which a theme very much of
this this for me is the infrastructure
gap in Africa and ways to try and
overcome that infrastructure gap the
interesting thing that came out of the
of this session I think was that on both
on the side of both the political
leaders and the private sector leaders
was the need very much to encourage a
greater dialogue for the private sector
to get together to discuss what they
want and to have more of a voice
collectively to go to the regional
leaders and to say this is what we need
to do to get over the obstacles so we
can have proper into economic
integration so businesses can grow so
jobs can be found for the for the many
people who will be the many young people
who will be making a far greater
proportion of the population of these
countries in the years to come